foreign
Ohio hi Steve how are you
great how are you better than I deserve
what's up
all right well thanks for taking my call
as of probably about a year ago you
didn't even know the days
but since then I've been listening radio
in your podcast well thank you
I'm very thank you so what I've done
since then I've already eliminated some
small debit cards on credit cards okay
your phone's going in and out if you can
speak directly into it maybe that'll
help
okay I'm sorry so so since then I have
refinanced my house from a five-year
or a 30-year five percent fixed rate to
the
15-year two and a half percent rate
which saved me a ton of money I would
have never known to have done that
unless I was listening to you guys cool
so now the only benefit that I have is
my house payment and the car payment but
what like kind of one of my questions is
then I have twenty two thousand dollars
in cash and a safety deposit box and I
probably keep about twenty thousand
dollars cash in my savings what would
you recommend that I do with that I'm 48
years old and have no retirement
okay so you're a hundred percent debt
free except you're home
except for the home and the truck
payment that I probably have like seven
thousand dollars okay first thing I'm
gonna do is pay off the truck
okay today
and now you're debt free and then you
need to set aside three to six months of
expenses as an emergency fund
of that money so what do you think three
to six months of expenses sounds like
um well my house payment is only 8.50 a
month so what's your household income
um so we're announcing Warren engaged
but just mine alone I make forty dollars
an hour and I average probably about 45
hours
okay so will you pay taxes on a year
um I think it's around 23 2400.
a year
yep now what's your annual incomes what
I'm asking oh my angel is my annual
income for me is probably about 80 000
that's what I was thinking okay okay I'm
sorry so let's call three to six months
of expenses twenty thousand bucks for
the fun of it
okay and we're gonna set that money
aside and never touch it for anything
it's there just as an umbrella when it
rains
yeah I don't want to I don't want to
kind of do it anymore I don't want to
kind of do it I want to label it that
and then never touch it
okay I have kind of forgotten about it
yeah unless there's an emergency you
don't touch it
and our new bass boat is not an
emergency
I understand that yeah okay and so every
time since I've been listening to you
I'm like do I really need this
then the rest of it we're going to move
on to the other baby steps and start
your retirement account and you need to
set up a Roth IRA and anything else you
can set up to get going on your savings
and start saving for retirement
okay and your your smartvester pro can
help you with that if you just go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on
smartvestor and so Christine that's an
example of a lot of that guy's a natural
saver
he's done a good job yeah really good
job I mean he's got money there and he's
got not got much debt a little seven
thousand dollar truck payment way ahead
of most Americans by far you know but
but he's sitting there and he but he's
listless and hasn't yet used the power
of His income to not only get out of
that first but then to point it towards
something other than just piling up cash
in a safe deposit box
and start pointing it towards wealth
building because if the inflation rate
is nine percent and that's what they say
it is that means every uh ten thousand
dollars that is in there is losing nine
hundred dollars a year
out
in two years that's two thousand dollars
you lost sitting in the safe deposit box
in purchasing power
right and so you can't let money just
sit in a stack of Benjamins it goes down
in value and um I remember when I first
got on the air I had this whole
hillbilly guy called me I loved it as a
great call because people it reminded me
my whole growing up years and he's like
yeah I got twenty thousand dollars
buried in a coffee can somewhere out in
the yard what do you think of that I'm I
think that's really dumb on a whole
bunch of fronts
number one your neighbor might have a
metal detector and he's out there with a
beep beep beep looking around in the
middle of the night you wonder what's
going on out there uh number two uh
paper left with moisture around it and
bugs will deteriorate you might go out
there and find nothing but a little pile
of confetti where your money used to be
and number three you know what twenty
thousand dollars is in seven years it's
forty thousand dollars you know what it
is in seven more years it's eighty
thousand dollars you know what it is and
seven more years 160 000 and so in the
last 21 years you have lost a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars with that
money sitting in a coffee can you know I
think I'm gonna dig it up I think you
need to son
so that you know that's called
opportunity cost we talk about that in
High Finance it's the missed opportunity
that the money could have had yep yeah
and I think it's awesome that he's a
natural saver because when somebody like
this finds a plan then they typically
get on fire and they're good at
executing they're we're not having to
deal with changing habits we're not
having to deal with you know cutting off
a spending bleed but this person's gonna
find this and just dive in and be on
track for wealth quickly
a spending bleed
pendingly there could be a spending
bleed in the culture
people could there could be a lot of
people bleeding to death with their
spending bleed yeah that's very possible
yeah because what you're talking about
is most people spend more than they make
they spend money like they're in
Congress right and uh you know he's not
he's doing a really good job so well
it's like if you've got the spending
blade we have not only the principles
that you need to learn yeah
we cannot stop the bleeding baby it's
what we do